bonjour il est l'heure de la question du
jour sujet international aujourd'hui la
guerre en Ukraine toujours au cœur de
l'actualité et nous vous demandons
aujourd'hui ceci les occidentaux ont-ils
raison de fournir des chars légers à
l'Ukraine vous avez vu passer ses
annonces j'en suis certain les Français
les Américains les Allemands vont
fournir des blindés aux Ukrainiens n'en
en parle avec Amaury Coutances bonjour
bonjour Thibault Gautier
alors expliquez-moi parce que ces
annonces tombent pourquoi maintenant
c'est une très bonne question la visite
du ministre des Armées Sébastien Lecornu
la semaine il y a deux semaines
maintenant à s'en douter des on sait que
le Président de la République est
toujours très engagé dans son soutien à
l'Ukraine
c'est système de combat était demandé de
longue date par les Ukrainiens les
Ukrainiens voulaient déjà beaucoup plus
lourds que ces engins de reconnaissance
blindée dont nous allons parler
aujourd'hui il y a une facilité qui a
été créée par l'Union l'idée c'est qu'il
y a un fond spécial qui est créé que
tout le monde peut abonder et avec ses
sous on peut acheter à des entreprises
européennes ou américaines du matériel
d'accord mais j'ai vu qu'avant notamment
les Allemands ne voulaient pas livrer de
char ça se débloque là petit à petit
pourquoi avant on ne voulait pas et
maintenant on peut c'est vraiment
technique alors voilà en fait c'est
technique c'est mais tout ça tient en
fait à la langue anglaise ah bon
en fait ce que l'on voit là le AMX 10 RC
donc ce calibré la France et voilà
magnifique c'est un engin de
reconnaissance blindée que l'on appelle
en anglais un tank destroyer donc un
chasseur de chars mais il y a une
deuxième qualification de char qui est
main battle tank pardon pour l'anglais
qui est un char qui est beaucoup plus
lourd qui est par exemple le char
Leclerc que nous connaissons en France
d'accord les Ukrainiens eux demandaient
aux Allemands des chars léopard 2 qui
sont des mains battle tank beaucoup plus
gros beaucoup plus importants
ce sont là on voit pour ceux qui nous
écoutent mes amis 10 RC exactement
ce sont les engins à roux et la raison
pour laquelle les Allemands sont
sollicités pour livrer leurs chars et
par deux et pourquoi pas nous les chars
Leclerc c'est que les chariots par 2
sont toujours en production que en plus
de ça ils ont été vendus par exemple à
la Pologne et un certain nombre d'États
riverains de l'Ukraine ce qui fait que
pour les lignes de production avoir des
pièces ou la réparation ce serait
beaucoup plus simple là où le char
Leclerc n'est plus en fabrication depuis
2008 et donc il aurait été beaucoup plus
difficile évidemment non seulement dans
livré parce qu'on n'a pas de pièces le
deuxième main battle tank qui est en
service toujours merci beaucoup c'est le
char américain Abrams d'accord je vous
rappelle la question du jour les
occidentaux ont-ils raison de fournir
des chars légers à l'Ukraine vous dites
oui vous dites non on découvrira vos
résultats tout à l'heure il y a une
coordination là donc entre entre les
pays j'imagine ce n'est pas la France
qui ont le fait PAF par hasard les
Américains font et paf par hasard les
Allemands font effectivement il y a des
manœuvres diplomatiques qui se qui sont
mis entre les chancellerines néanmoins
il faut connaître que pour une fois la
France a été en avance et qu'elle l'a
avancé avant qu'elle annonçait avant
l'envoi donc de MX AMX 10 RC lors d'une
conversation téléphonique entre les
présidents Hélène ski et Macron
l'Allemagne était sous pression depuis
un certain nombre de semaines pour
livrer des chars et elle a annoncé
effectivement l'envoi de char mardeur
qui sont des l'équivalent allemand DMX
10 RC avec quelques spécificités sur
lesquelles on pourra revenir et les
Américains envoient également le même
genre de matériel la différence entre
notre les Américains il n'envoient pas
du lourd non plus non ils envoient
exactement la même chose c'est-à-dire
des des engins de reconnaissance
blindées la différence entre les
équipements américains allemands et
français c'est que notre notre canon est
plus gros d'accord et parce que ça tient
ça tient à une doctrine en usage dans
l'armée française que peu de pays dans
le monde ont c'est-à-dire que nous nos
engins de reconnaissance blindée pour
parcours de vont foncer dans le tas et
si jamais il doit y avoir du combat vont
tirer grâce à leur canon de 105 mm qui
se sont effectivement prévu pour faire
de l'antichard que l'on voit là
où les les Allemands et les Américains
sont des engins blindés comme cela donc
ils peuvent effectivement faire de la
reconnaissance technique faire de
l'appui feu avec des des soldats au sol
mais en revanche on des canons beaucoup
plus petit de 20 mm donc c'est plutôt
des des grosses mitrailleuses pour
résumer je comprends ce que vous voulez
me dire alors
qui livre quoi combien on enlève donc
nous c'est la mx-10rc absolument
l'armée française alors non on ne sait
ni combien on en livre ni dans quel
délai nous allons les livrer pour le
moment pour le moment c'est extrêmement
flou c'est seulement une annonce je
pense qu'on sera lorsque la France a
annoncé l'envoi de canon César c'est
canon extrêmement performant qui sont
capables de tirer à plus de 40 km de
distance avec une précision de de 50
mètres on avait au début pas donné le
nombre ni le délai pour des questions de
sécurité et pour que évidemment les
Russes ne ciblent pas finalement on a
réussi à quelques quelques semaines
après leur livraison et leur mise en
service ni les américains ni les
Allemands n'ont communiqué le délai ou
le nombre des véhicules qui seront
envoyés ce que l'on sait en revanche
c'est que la France possède un peu plus
de 240 de ces AMX alors combien on en
donne parce que s'il faut un pourcentage
donc on sait pas mais on sait pas un
ordre d'idée 10%, 15 20% on ne sait pas
on ne sait honnêtement on ne sait pas
encore en revanche qu'il faut
246 246 ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
ce sont des véhicules qui sont en cours
de remplacement ils ont été conçus dans
les années 70 mise en service au début
des années 80 ils étaient en fait conçus
pour affronter les chars soviétiques
dans les guerre froide et que on avait
on les avait conçus pour que un régiment
de ces AMX puisse combat 3 à 4 régiments
des T62 et T70 russe et enfin soviétique
et une nouvellement russe aujourd'hui ce
sont des donc des véhicules en cours de
remplacement finalement ce qu'on donne
aux Ukrainiens c'est des
véhicule que la France n'utiliserait
plus une utilisation
en fait on produit aujourd'hui des
nouveaux des nouveaux engins de
véhicules de reconnaissance et de
véhicules blindés qui sont les jaguars
qui vont remplacer les IMX à l'horizon
2030 2035 sont des beaucoup plus
performants en fait c'est ces véhicules
n'ont jamais été utilisés pour combattre
le pack de Varsovie et l'Union
soviétique ils ont été utilisés pendant
la première guerre du Golfe on
Afghanistan et même récemment au cl donc
ce sont des véhicules dont que l'armée
française va remplacer ça ne va donc pas
pénaliser l'armée française je pense que
c'est très important de dire ça aux gens
qui nous écoutent on ne va pas
déshabiller Pierre pour habiller Paul ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas l'idée de l'armée
française l'armée française jusqu'à
présent à part les les véhicules de
l'avant blindé et les canons César n'a
pas mis n'a pas donné aux Ukrainiens des
véhicules qui peuvent nous pénaliser ce
sont soit des des matériels qui sont en
cours de remplacement soit des matériels
qui sont anciens et pour lesquels on a
des occidentaux ont-ils raison de
fournir des chars légers c'est la
question du jour j'attends un peu avant
de dévoiler votre votre réponse pourquoi
on n'en voit pas très clairement des des
chars Leclerc c'est notre fleuron ça
c'est tout à fait c'est le Flon de
l'armée française et c'est même l'un des
fleurons occidentaux puisque le Charles
Leclerc est l'un des seuls le seul chat
au monde à pouvoir tirer en roulant 60
degrés par exemple les Abrahams
américains dont nous avons parlé tout à
l'heure et même les Léopards de allemand
ne sont pas capables de faire la même
chose la raison est très simple pour
laquelle on ne livre pas les les chats
français c'est que on a plus de ligne de
production et donc si on devait donner
pour le coup des chars Leclerc on ne
serait pas capable de ou alors il
faudrait relancer une ligne de
production ce qui serait très cher on
pour le coup on pénaliserait l'armée
française les chats en production dans
le monde sont les Abrahams Américains et
les Léopards Allemands eux pourraient
être livrés pourquoi est-ce qu'on les
livre pas je pense que pour le moment
les
Occidentaux sont un peu frileux il faut
quand même se souvenir en fait ce qui
est très intéressant avec ces livraisons
d'armes depuis le début du conflit c'est
que il correspondre et on en avait déjà
parlé d'ailleurs sur ce plateau à chaque
fois à des périodes particulières du
conflit au début on livrait vous
souvenez on en avait parlé des gilets
pare-balles puis progressivement on est
monté en gamme jusqu'à aujourd'hui
c'est une question moi j'ai parié avec
un collègue journaliste juste avant que
l'on pas que l'on livre des chars que
l'on allait livrer déjà honnêtement la
prochaine étape et difficile à imaginer
peut-être des chars lourds peut-être des
avions honnêtement on ne sait pas à
l'heure où on parle on sait par exemple
les Américains les Ukrainiens demandent
aux Américains des missiles qu'on
appelle attaquems qui ont une très très
longue portée qui en fait même la portée
de frapper Moscou par exemple si jamais
ils étaient livrés pour le moment ils ne
sont pas livrés sont frileux aussi sur
cette extrêmement frileux en fait la
question de ce que l'on appelle la
cobellie gérance depuis le début du
conflit obsède les chancellerie on a
peur que les Russes qui d'ailleurs
disent ouvertement qui nous qui se
battent contre les pilotants et contre
l'Occident ce disque il se met
définitivement contre le temps avec
l'Occident et peut ouvrir aller en
guerre contre le temps sur un territoire
de
c'est vraiment la crainte des
Occidentaux c'est absolument ce que l'on
veut empêcher et je pense que c'est ce
qui a limité pendant un certain temps
les livraisons de de certains armements
à l'Ukraine néanmoins l'Ukraine est
toujours très demandée ça fait un
certain temps qu'elle demande des chats
beaucoup plus lourds je rappelle cette
question du jour les occidentaux ont-ils
raison de fournir des chars légers
de vous poser les bases j'en viens
progressivement à notre question on sait
ce que ça nous coûte là d'envoyer des
charges on n'a pas le nombre mais on
sait le prix d'un chat on va pouvoir le
déterminer à peu près le les prix ne
sont pas toujours communiqués il faut
toujours évidemment les relativiser le
prix naturellement dépendra de l'envoi
mais aussi évidemment fin du nombre que
l'on veut envoyer mais aussi du
transport le nom pour le moment est
encore inconnu comme le nombre de
véhicules aussi parce que c'est vrai
qu'il y avait exactement des munitions
donc ça aussi combien ça c'est une très
bonne question en plus ça va être une
vraie galère logistique pour les
Ukrainiens parce que c'est char comme on
en a parlé ont des canons de 105 mm
alors qu'ils sont habitués à des vieux
chasse soviétiques qui ont du 20 mm donc
c'est des munitions encore différentes
c'est à dire qu'il faut stocker ces
missions différentes les acheminer sur
le front même si ce sont des engins qui
sont extrêmement performants ce sont des
nécessitent des munitions particulières
et encore une fois pour revenir sur les
phases particulières du conflit les
Ukrainiens alerte sur une potentielle
attaque depuis la Biélorussie des Russes
qui viendraient vers Kiev oui on a vu la
ces derniers jours d'ailleurs des
ukraides qui arrivaient en Biélorussie
en train avec des armes exactement et
encore aujourd'hui un nouveau train est
arrivé à Minsk c'est vraiment quelque
chose qu'il craigne ce genre de véhicule
par exemple permettrait de d'harceler
les lignes russes pour
compliquer leur logistique mais aussi
détruire certains de leurs chars c'est
à dire que la diplomation européenne et
occidentale anticipent une telle attaque
honnêtement c'est pas très difficile de
l'imaginer est-ce que finalement c'est
Charles qu'on voit c'est amix-10rc
est-ce qu'ils sont plus performants que
ce qu'on les Russes
ça dépend les engins des Russes en
revanche c'est ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure ils sont très capables
d'aller détruire un certain nombre de
chars russes il était 62 l'été 70 qui
sont par exemple très déployés dans le
bon baisse je pense que en fait la
doctrine d'emploi de ces véhicules va
vraiment dépendre de ce que de ce qui va
se passer dans les prochaines semaines
les Russes vont-ils attaquer les
Ukrainiens auront-ils l'initiative va
être ça c'est vraiment la question qui
va se poser d'ici à je pense mars le
temps que le climat se reforme que tout
le monde recomplète ses armées l'Ukraine
a annoncé vouloir former trois nouveaux
corps d'armée c'est à dire 75000 hommes
d'ici à mars 2023 pour pouvoir
poursuivre une offensive je vous pose
donc la question à Mori les occidentaux
ont-ils raison de fournir des chars
légers la France à l'Ukraine la France
a-t-elle raison de fournir des charges à
l'Ukraine oui ou non quel est l'intérêt
de la France d'ailleurs dans tout ça et
l'intérêt de la France c'est de le
président de la République a eu
plusieurs déclarations qui n'ont pas été
comprise sur l'avenir de la relation de
la France et l'Occident avec la Russie
on se souvient des fameuses garanties de
sécurité la France doit évidemment
montrer qu'elle est toujours dans le
co-occidental ce dont finalement
personne n'a véritablement jamais douté
livrer de telles armements permettrait
effectivement à l'Ukraine de continuer à
résister et je pense qu'en fait au-delà
des chars légers la question qu'il faut
se poser c'est que veut-on faire ensuite
si jamais on veut que la l'issue de
cette guerre soit la défaite complète de
la Russie et ça la destruction d'une
partie de son armement le retour des
frontières de 91 de toute façon il va
falloir continuer à livrer un certain
nombre d'armes qui seront adaptés à des
instants de combat donc vous me dites
plutôt oui moi je vous dis plutôt oui
alors regardons ce qu'on pense aux
internautes et bien ils sont d'accord
avec vous à près de
68% voilà vous continuez à voter
évidemment alors Macron Emmanuel Macron
ne cesse de dire non non nous ne sommes
pas en guerre contre la Russie on croit
de moins en moins donc quand on voit ces
livraisons d'armes qui sont de plus en
plus performantes mais vous posez
vraiment la question essentielle c'est
une notion que personne n'arrive
véritablement à définir depuis le début
on parle de cobelli gérance le problème
de cette notion c'est que en fait c'est
l'adversaire qui définit si vous êtes
cobellisant ou non nous on livre
seulement désarmement à un pays alliés
qui est agressé par une puissance
étrangère qui en plus de ça est un
compétiteur stratégique nous ne sommes
pas en guerre on est juste dans une
compétition stratégique avec une
puissance concurrente donc pour
l'instant c'est une ligne de Crète enfin
je veux dire notre ami notre ami
peut-être pas Vladimir Poutine lui
comment il prend tout ça et qu'elle peut
être sa réaction parce que lui depuis le
début il dit si si regardez nous sommes
en guerre avec les Occidentaux qui
lisent des armes mais il ne répond pas
franchement aux Occidentaux en tout cas
d'un point de vue guerrier il n'attaque
pas l'Occident mais lui pour le coup
tout son discours et toute sa toute sa
verve elle rencontre de l'Ukraine et de
dire vous avez un pays qui était l'une
de mes marches et j'avais décidé de la
neutraliser de la mettre sous mon joule
les occidentaux le sont venus me le
voler aujourd'hui je me combat
l'Occident et je vais aller repousser
leur œuvre d'ailleurs satanique on a eu
des mots comme ça etc il y a évidemment
un combat d'énarratif ça c'est normal
[Musique]
une raison de fournir des chars légers à
l'Ukraine voilà pour ce cette question
du jour vous pouvez évidemment la
retrouver en replay sur le figero.fr sur
Youtube si vous arrivez seulement
maintenant hop vous recommencez on est
resté un petit quart d'heure ensemble et
vous avez toutes toutes les explications
d'Amaury la suite du programme c'est
point de vue c'est dans allez 11 minutes
le résumé de la semaine avec Guillaume
Rocket directeur de la rédaction du
Figaro Magazine qui rejoint en plateau
Vincent roux nous on se dit à la semaine
prochaine excellent weekend sur le
figarolive